نقدم لك Apple watch series 5 التي
تتميز بشاشة جديدة مبتكرة
تكون دائمًا على شاشة Retina الجديدة التي تعمل دائمًا
لا تنام أبدًا ، لذلك يكون وجه الساعة
مرئيًا دائمًا مع الطرز
السابقة لساعة Apple عندما تخفض
معصمك ، ستصبح الشاشة
مظلمة تمامًا ولكن الآن مع  السلسلة 5 ، ستكون دائمًا
قادرًا على رؤية وقتك ومضاعفاتك ،
عند رفع معصمك أو نقرة تعيد كل شيء
إلى السطوع الكامل الآن
، تم تحميل الشاشة الجديدة التي تعمل دائمًا للتو
بتقنيات متقدمة ، لذلك أريد أن
أخبرك عن كل شيء يبدأ بـ
تسمح شاشة العرض المصنوعة من مادة البولي السيليكون والأكسيد ذات درجة الحرارة المنخفضة الوحيدة في الصناعة أو LTP Oh LTP بتحديث الشاشة
ديناميكيًا من 60 هرتز إلى
مستوى منخفض يصل إلى هرتز واحد وهو موفر للطاقة للغاية ،
وهناك أيضًا
برنامج تشغيل شاشة عرض منخفض الطاقة جديد وإدارة طاقة فائقة الكفاءة
دائرة متكاملة
ومستشعر إضاءة محيطة جديد
يعملان معًا بسلاسة من خلال الجمع بين
هذا الجهاز المذهل والبرامج المبتكرة التي
نتمتع بها  le لتقديم هذه
الشاشة التي تعمل دائمًا مع الاستمرار في
الحفاظ على نفس عمر البطارية لمدة 18 ساعة طوال اليوم
[تصفيق]
إذا كانت دائمًا معروضة على الشاشة ، وبوصلة
المكالمات الدولية للطوارئ وجميع
الميزات الرائعة الأخرى مثل دليل السباحة ،
يمكنك إجراء اكتشاف سقوط مخطط كهربية القلب
Apple  ادفع جميع الميزات الجديدة للساعة
إلينا ستة ، إنها حقًا ساعة Apple الأكثر قدرة على
الإطلاق من طراز Series Five GPS
ستبدأ بثلاثة وتسعين و
4.99 دولارًا فقط للطرازات الخلوية ، وستتمكن
من طلب السلسلة الخامسة بدءًا من اليوم
مباشرة بعد  الكلمة الرئيسية
وستتوفر في متاجرنا اعتبارًا من
20 سبتمبر
[موسيقى]